[Music]
hey let's go to
uh tony in rochester new york what's up
tony
hey thank you for taking my call um i
don't want to stereotype but you realize
tony's the
most new york name possible that's
incredible
thank you
i needed a tony from new york today i'm
glad you called what's up brother how
can i help
um i own a construction company and i'm
having trouble just like disconnecting
from work and being me and it's
i really don't remember who i was prior
to this
oh man tell me about that is it blown up
is it just gone bananas
yeah i i do very well um
i have there's six of us total so i'm
just always working working and right
now we're just months and months out and
it's just
all i do is think about work and like i
never can kind of be present in the
moment and
it's struggling with like marriage i
have a
toddler she's almost two um so it's just
hard to
like i remember when i worked for
someone else i didn't i just came home
and i lived my life but now
my life is i'm kind of like defined by
my business every time i see people it's
oh i was worth going and i say the same
thing every time busy
i'm not i don't know where i am anymore
really
so man
you're one of the most self-aware men
i've ever talked to
like it usually takes 15 counseling
sessions to get to that what you just
said
that's incredible
tell me about it i'm in class so okay
maybe i've been in a bunch there you go
so um tell me about your wife how long
you been married tell me about her
we've been married for four years we've
been together for
i believe nine years now she's awesome
yeah i love her a lot and
she told me the other day that
all like all kind of like our issues and
like i've changed since i started a
business
and she's right right probably
probably or yeah she's right yeah yeah
she's right
so um how much do you make in a a year
what's your take home gonna be
a lot um
over 100
maybe close to two okay
what about last year
i think that i think it was like 150.
okay
what about the year before
probably under 100. okay
what's enough what's the goal line here
i don't know
um i
you know you got a picture in your head
what's the goal line
well i don't know if i want to go bigger
if i just want to stay where i am like
when you i was thinking about this the
other day you open up a restaurant okay
like i run a restaurant that's where i'm
going to be either i'm going to
franchise i'm not going to franchise
like expand but with with me i can have
at a crew take away a crew do i want to
go big or not there's just so many
possibilities like what kind of work do
i want to do
what field do i want to be in
i i don't truly know
at first i wanted to just go big and
when i went big i got up to like 10 guys
i was like well this is
a lot of work it's a lot yeah yeah
and if you're really good at
construction and you're really good at
bidding and you're good at managing
project projects that's a whole
different skill set than trying to
navigate 10 crew members and their crazy
lives and are they going to show up in
their light and their flat tires and
their marriage drama and all that
so
you're trying to figure out your
business blew up you're clearly good at
what you do clearly i mean you're good
at it you're talented at it and that's
awesome
have you asked the question what kind of
dad do i want to be
what kind of husband do i want to be and
then you let those answers inform your
business
i don't think i've asked myself that
specifically but i thought of that i
don't want
i don't want to use words
put a picture in my head
of the dad you want to be
i want to be the dad that i didn't have
someone who's there and present and what
does that mean what does that mean
they're present that's those are just
like those are out of a hallmark card
they're in present paint me a picture of
it
just involved with like just ah like
like an actual picture an actual picture
i'm gonna be the guy who picks my my son
or daughter up from soccer practice
mom's gonna have to get her there
because i'm at work but i'm gonna be the
guy that picks him up i'm gonna be the
guy that has a little bit too short of
shorts on on saturday morning it's
freezing cold but i'm out there watching
the soccer game cheering like mad and i
don't even i don't even know what's
happening like paint me a picture
yeah i want to be
there for like every big moment of her
life just
killing it really so listen listen she's
going to school at events or anything
just being there and
spending time with her and growing with
her
so here's what i want you to do and i
want you to do this with your wife
because it's gonna be hard especially
your dad
sucked uh yeah he kind of gave up on us
and my mom died when i was like 3.
so here's what you're dealing with
you're dealing with the right heart
not even the right heart an incredible
heart tony
but you don't have a picture of what
this looks like and when you don't have
a picture of what this looks like it's a
lot of platitudes and here's what those
platitudes become
never enough
you will miss soccer games and you will
miss a play every once in a while
because you're running a business and
you're working your butt off and you're
providing for your family it's going to
happen
and so when you have expectations like i
just want to be there for her for every
major moment
that's a noble idea
but it's it's going to set you up to
always feel like a failure because you
can't be there for everyone
my dad was an amazing guy
and
every major dance that i can remember
one of my neighborhood dads had to tie
my tie because my dad was out
doing awesome stuff
do i regret it do i hate him no man he
was working hard and i never for one
second doubted they loved me and i got
to make some great relationships with
some of the neighborhood dads i just
grew up in that kind of neighborhood
that every like i was getting parented
by 20 different parents growing up
but it's still to this day like the joke
is man i
mike stewart tied my tie randy fox tied
my ties before major dances and stuff
because my dad was insane does that make
sense so here's the thing i want you to
speak very specifically and then this is
what it might sound like
i want to be a dad who has the entire
soccer schedule and i'm gonna make five
out of the seven games
and if they're on saturdays i'm never
gonna miss them ever i'm gonna i'm gonna
pay somebody to be on call for those
saturday mornings and it may cost me a
thousand bucks because there may be a
pipe that burst on one of the set on one
of the
um construction construction zones that
we're working on
um but he's gonna go fix it because i'm
not gonna miss that soccer game
and then the other side of it is there's
gonna be some games i miss
and i'mma give myself grace on those
because my daughter knows i love him
knows i love her i'm gonna read a book
every night of the week to my daughter
every single day i will read a book
i will hug my daughter for 30 seconds
every day
so what i'm saying is i want you to
begin to paint pictures not use words
because you my brother are changing
family trees
you are changing legacy i'll even dare
to say your road is harder than mine
because i had a picture of what an
awesome dad looks like
you don't so you are painting something
new does that make sense
yeah because like right now i just kind
of well all i know is like to provide
and i'm trying to that's right well
here's what's gonna happen
that goal post is always gonna move on
you
it will never not move on you because
there's always gonna be a nicer private
school they could go to or you could get
him a bmw instead of a crappy corolla
for wait right you know what i mean like
that goal supposed to always move until
you sit down with your wife and then
i want you to sit down and say this kind
of husband i'm going to be
and this is what this is going to look
like on a day-to-day basis
so in my house tony i asked him and this
is 25 years of doing it wrong
i asked my wife we've been dating 25
years we've been married 19.
how can i help today
what does your picture of today look
like what do you need from me this week
and that's not romantic it's not sexy
but it's awesome
does that make sense
and then i backfill my profession from
there
i back work it comes after i decide what
kind of husband i'm going to be now i'm
about to hit the road in the next few
months i'm going to be gone a lot and so
we've sat down and have calendar
meetings every week we have done set
some dates on the calendar when we're
going to go out we've got some dates
where we're going to we're going to go
have a weekend together when i'm home
for a week whatever
um i've had to put some hunting trips
and special trips on the calendar with
me and my son so we don't lose that i
mean my daughter but so i've had to be
hyper intentional about drop making sure
those pictures are gonna be that way and
i know it come december i'm gonna be
exhausted i know i am
and that's all right man but we're being
intentional and we're being very clear
about what this is gonna look like what
success will look like and what failure
will look like does that make sense
yeah so you're saying basically if i set
if i figure out draw a picture of where
i want my family left to be and where i
want to be as a husband and father and
also
where i want my business to be
it will help me those things i won't
focus so much on the business and i'll
focus more on what comes first and
rather than it will but it's going to
let you when you are in the business
you're going to be all in
so when i'm at work i'm not worried like
i wonder do i need to come get my son
today do i i don't have to worry about
that i know exactly where i need to be
afterwards and so when i'm here at work
i am a thousand percent in
growing this thing making it big taking
speaking engagements i'm gonna miss a
lot of stuff this fall i know i am
and i've already put some stuff on the
calendar not to make up because i don't
have to make things up
but just so i can continue to be the
husband and dad that i said i wanted to
be
and you have that exact heart
if not more
the challenge you have is you've got a
bunch of energy going 5 000 different
directions
and so what i want you to do is to sit
down and be hyper intentional about i
want to be this kind of dad
i want to be this kind of husband i want
to
let those inform i want to be this kind
of leader i want to have this kind of
construction dude brother you can have
the biggest construction company in
the state of new york
and you're going to have three or four
incredible senior associate vice
presidents who run things because you're
going to go home and get that game
you're gonna take your kiss disneyland
does that make sense
yeah yeah i just gotta figure out what i
wanna what i wanna get to and where i
wanna be that's it right but listen to
me the key here is don't use words use
pictures
because you're going to say things like
i want to be a super present husband i'm
a and you can look at your wife and
you're going to have a tearful moment
you're going to say i'm going to be the
dad that is always here i'm going to be
the husband that always shows up and
she's going to say oh it's so great and
show up for her is gonna mean you're
there at 4 30 every day
and show up for you means
two or three days a week i'm not home
till 8 o'clock because i'm leaving i'm
leaving the site
but a couple days a week i'm at home and
we're going to we're going to watch a tv
show together
and so what a picture gets you is gets
everybody on the same page
so when you say i'm gonna i'm gonna be
that kind of dad here's exactly what
that will look like
i'm gonna make most of the games
or this particular hey honey we got a
new building it's a multi-million dollar
project i'm gonna miss a lot of games
this year and that means in the mornings
i'm gonna do long hugs i'm gonna do
bedtime when i can i'm gonna do weekend
duty does that make see what i'm saying
there we're painting pictures of what
this stuff's gonna look like and that
way you're on the same page with your
daughter and any other kids to come
you're on the same page with your spouse
and most importantly you're on the same
page with you
because now you're not just running this
endless race
of just trying to be somebody that your
dad wasn't
trying to be that parent that you're
when your mom passed away
no i got a clear picture and i'm running
towards that
and then you can hit that man and then
when you're at work oh my gosh you're
going to crush work because you're going
to be all in i want to be this kind of
leader i want to be this kind of boss i
want to be this kind of
um when my name when my company takes a
job we're going to have this kind of
reputation because i'm going to lean
into that and then when i'm at home you
can talk to me tomorrow guys
because i love you guys but i love my
wife and my little girl more you know i
have to shake that off call tom he's on
call bye guys
you're gonna find out
every ship in your harbor is going to
rise
when you say this is this is me being
intentional what a stud tony
you've made my day better brother i'm so
grateful for the call and to all the
dads out there who feel like they're
running 500 different different
directions either i just lost the job
that mattered to me or my job exploded
underneath me i don't know what to do
and i feel like i'm not being the
husband i'm not being the wife i'm not
being the dad but
start with pictures
start with this is what it's going to
look like when it's enough this is what
it's going to look like
when i can breathe this is what it's
going to look like today when today is
done
and then i can go home and put my feet
up it's going to be good
and go tell your wife today tony changes
today tony from new york changes
and we're gonna make new pictures
together it's gonna be awesome thank you
so much for your call brother